I find it funny that no one really gave
a [ __ ] to watch this movie this last
weekend so since I'm getting you this
review late I'm going to tell you it's
some spoiler ish things that I wouldn't
really tell you in the actual review if
I got it up early and made more than an
abysmal opening seriously this movie
made too much though I know it made it
made [ __ ] and it made more than it
should have
pan so pan is the telling of the origin
story of Peter Pan kind of but you know
it's a fresh new take it's darker it's
pretty much Disney's answered a fan for
stay it's a darker more boring telling
of an origin story of characters you're
familiar with it you should be having
fun with you just hate the entire time
Peter Pan's in an orphanage livestock's
a bunch of pirates take a bunch of kids
there and they take them to Neverland
where Blackbeard played by Hugh Jackman
has a bunch of slave labor and they're
mining for pixie does and halfway
through this movie I knew there was a
problem because we were halfway through
we were still in this stupid mine and
it's Neverland this is a land literally
of imagination it's a land of dreams
anything is possible so for the first
half of this movie here in this
boring-ass Brown mine and I was like
alright when we get off the second read
Blood Diamond set maybe it'll get better
it never really does I just had to roll
my eyes at the fact that in this movie
Peter Pan has three days to learn how to
fly holy [ __ ] that's the plot a hook
you're not pulling from a superior Peter
Pan movie and you're just doing it worse
he meets James Hook along the way in the
mine I this dude this dude I don't know
what cartoon this guy was doing but this
guy he always talks like out of the
corner of his hat he's always like James
James huh I was like what version of
American at what is that I'll tell you
what it is
is what other countries think Americans
talk like I'm here guys we don't all
sound like that in fact the majority of
us don't just always see Americans who
look and talk and act like hook in this
movie on the news because they're always
talking about what the UFO looked like
or they just giving Kim Davis high five
names James Hook I don't know what he's
channeling I got nothing for you
and the origin story of Peter Pan in
hook being friends would have been cool
if there was some inkling of hook in
this character but there just wasn't
Rooney Mara was in this movie as Tiger
Lily I guess alright hey don't flood my
comment section with a whitewashed Tiger
Lily get it that is the palest woman
ever granted I love pale chicks so that
is awesome
good job Rooney Mara Tiger Lily I don't
know about that but I mean fine she
totally crushed throne she was really
good in the movie but I just could have
been anybody and of course I have to
make Peter Pan some Messiah some like
Jesus Pan where it's this prophecy where
this kid's gonna come out of nowhere who
can fly and he's gonna take out
Blackbeard which is the easiest plot
device to do in a movie and it just I
hate it when they do it with characters
who were free established characters
that we know from our
childhood and we love and they're like
hey we'll just make it a prophecy and
that's why he's that no because it
creates a rift and now divides you from
the character Peter Pan was cool because
kids wanted to be Peter Pan they didn't
want to grow up but now he's enough he's
Pan Jesus all right well now I can't be
like in because we're not messiahs I
hated that they did it with Darth Vader
I'm not super attached to the character
of Peter Pan I just hate that they do
that in movies stop it make him a
character don't just billow you news
prophecy it's just easier this way but
still you're thinking all right maybe
it'll show Peter Pan and hook me friends
and in hooks gonna screw him over and
that's how they become enemies gonna
lose his hand to the crocodile none of
that should happen this movie ends with
hook being friends with Peter Pan and he
kind of has this romance with Tiger Lily
that's [ __ ] that you don't buy still
has it's handy to do they just go on in
their adventures like alright kid should
just ride the rack straight down till
morning I was like all they're doing
that thing where they're setting up for
a sequel or a trilogy totally gonna
happen guys in the end pants sucked it
was terrible the character sucked the
premise suck it's not for kids it's not
for adults I would say maybe it's for
kids if at the beginning kids weren't
getting kicked off a plank and falling
down a cliff to their death it's too
violent for kids too boring for adults
watch this movie I'll tell you what it
is
pan is [ __ ] well I guess this is just
another reimagining that didn't pan out
I guess so pan have you seen it one that
you didn't I you know one saw this movie
right so hook have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
a hook comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you wanna see more click right here
to see more
you